[Music]
all is quiet on this Urban Oasis
Chef Yoon prepares a mighty Feast for a
family of chains
nature lovers will know anything can
happen at the watering hole greetings
hello I have Halo women it's my son and
I have Harmony
hi guys I'm a Chef Joseph Yoon from
Brooklyn bugs
yeah
and uh
have any of you guys tried eating
insects before
no no and I would never try trouble at
the watering hole young Halo takes a
defensive stance on bugs how about you
have you tried now have you tried no
first first of all wait wait so they
told me a chef was coming right no one
told me this
you were a chef of edible insects edible
insects this is a thing this is most
certainly a thing you know the yuan is
trying to think about how can we
sustainably be the world's population in
2050 when the world's population is
gonna Burge into like 9 billion people
their idea is like hey what if we were
to add a nutrient dense sustainable and
delicious form of protein to diversify
our diet and I'm hoping that I could
convince you guys that we can prepare it
really deliciously and you eat bugs yeah
I eat it almost every day but I would
say like more days of the week that eat
it than I don't that's fascinating oh
why thank thank you so much Harmony all
of these are farmed or harvested
specifically for us to eat you know if
you get a bug that lands on your food
when you're outside those are not the
Bugs we're eating okay that's what I'm
asking right this is all farmed or
harvested specifically for us to eat
right what's that these here
that is a barbecue Cricket cheese puff
but spicy is it spicy it's just got like
onion powder and like garlic powder
everybody else try to we have to try it
yeah oh yeah
I don't know you can go ahead and try it
go try your book try it do you guys want
to try no no we're gonna pass on the
worms
I'll eat one of these okay okay cheers
like that look at that Cricket black ant
all right those are ants I'm sure I made
an animal accident ants have formic acid
as a defense mechanism what do you think
that formic acid could taste like nasty
on most of this stuff
Evolution at its finest Halo is already
embracing this new Delight but can he
sway his family the black ants have
formic acid okay and it gives it a
citrusy flavor and that's why I added it
on to the the tortilla chip with
guacamole I barely seasoned the
guacamole they're huge to make to make
to well and crickets the big ones are
crickets the black the blackheads
wait a minute right so yeah would you
like to try one of these yeah yeah it's
almost like a pop rock oh you just want
to eat an ant
yeah it's almost like pop rocks
okay well he eats that so the ant on
that plate yeah the thing that I
I no okay these are very different
that's what I'm saying like those ants
like you know what when I'm outside
camping and stuff I don't want those
ants like I'm in my tent I don't want
ants in my kitchen these are very
different uh these are very different
ants and everything
um
you want to try uh all right man
what you like put in your mouth and like
you squish it down tastes like like it
had this little juice come out
just like blueberry a little bit
blueberry this this attack I'm just I'm
in my head right now yeah with with the
word worms and stuff like and no and
that's that's I'm sure it's natural you
brought up a great idea because we don't
need cow right no we eat burgers and
steaks right we don't eat pig we eat
pork and bacon so we need to start
coming up with some new ideas besides
worms so I'm I'm with you on that see
what I'm saying two chains and like go
going back to idea like calamari homie
would you like to try anything if
there's anything tempt you anything
catch your eye let's ask Harmony first
son you know I got something that you
might like do you like potatoes yeah
kind of not really you like potatoes but
just not with bogs on them is that what
you're saying because we do have these
roasted potatoes and they're made with a
lot of butter pecorino Romano cheese a
little bit of cricket powder Cricket
powder
that gives it a little more nutrition
and like a really beautiful flavor just
the powder just the powder yeah not the
cricket not the cricket yeah what kind
of bug is on there
powder that's it that's it that's it
yeah oh don't tell me
um
you probably can't even taste the
Crickets probably just tastes really
good it's like potatoes
it just tastes like potatoes potatoes
say for real son
the circle of chains the sun has become
the teacher
watch as 2 Chainz takes his first step
into the world of edible insects
okay I'll try something
y'all are just eating it in my face so
there's like I should just eat it by now
no mine ain't bad no bug on here right
just a cricket powder
what's that this one here you know I
just wanted to show you like a A small
collection of my insects and you know
what's so wild about this all the
different flavors that come out of this
how you doing Harmony um it's okay
one thing that we haven't went through
is some prices and I'm afraid that
you're on this show because you're about
to tell me that eating bugs is expensive
how much a cricket per pound who gets
per power we're looking at 15 to 20
bucks a pound right okay but when we
look at like these black ants here half
an ounce of it it's like around 30 bucks
or so half a zip half an ounce of it's
like 30. it's half an ounce a pound of
it goes for like almost like 300 or
pound Advance yeah wait wait wait wait
wait yeah out of it
300 yeah right then like what would be
the most expensive bug out of every bug
in the world so far from what we're
looking at here right now
this scorpion here scorpion right these
Venturian scorpions if you get a pound
of this it's gonna run you about five
G's
right five what five thousand
is it Scorpion and uh really super
delicious
and crunchy no
no you did really the only limitation we
have in eating insects is our own
imagination that's right it's all the
stuff that I tasted was good my son
likes Bugs I don't know I'm so grateful
that you guys came here decided to try
some of the food and you know just
really kind of having an open mind I
really appreciate it thank you thank you
Chef thank you thank you let's go again
yeah definitely it's a total
free-for-all the bug Watering Hole the
rest of the cast and crew rushing in for
the scraps oh dang I had the dessert
over here guys these are our best full
of flavor Subs these are Japanese wasps
wasps yeah cured and sake
one year oh one year and then it's on a
Korean pear with some gold flakes in
honor of Two Chains and most
expensivists oh it is delicious oh okay
what is it now what is it we might need
to take two or two chains eating some of
these insects guys like it's a pig you
ate the wash yeah
[Music]
he's got some gold on your lips cheers
foreign